vous êtes là pour parler de manière
poétique et fantaisiste de la rentrée
scolaire avec pas moins de trois livres
coups de coeur c'est ça oui puisque la
rentrée c'est souvent finalement
synonyme de bon événement d'événements
joyeux pour les enfants qui sont
contentes se retrouver et de se lancer
dans de nouveaux défis
par exemple l'apprentissage de la
lecture alors pour apprivoiser les
lettres voici un abécédaire que j'ai
beaucoup aimée de pierre coran et d'iris
fossier publié par casterman alors c'est
un abécédaire en poème à chaque page on
découvre une nouvelle lettre mais aussi
de nouveaux sons grâce à des répétitions
et des allitérations alors par exemple
dans ce poème nommé le lama et le
lamentin et bien on entend ceci quand
sur le pont de leur bateau un lamantin
et un lama se croient des chanteurs
d'opéra les passagers plonge sous l'eau
tant les deux marins chante faux alors
vous le voyez c'est un vrai bonheur de
naviguer au milieu des collages de
cépages et des rimes et je pense que les
enfants seront moins intimidés par la
lecture grâce à ce livre puisque on ne
voit plus les mots comme des monstres un
qu'il faut déchiffrer mais plutôt comme
des animaux apprivoisés pour se raconter
et bien ses propres histoires super
super moi j'aime ce qui est bien c'est
que parfois des histoires pour enfants
deviennent aussi réalité et vous êtes
venus avec des juke r ce matin ils
viennent pas tous franchement d'un jeu
de cartes mais d'une classe de cm1 faut
nous expliquer vous pouvez vous faire
passer un juste omis je vous en donne à
un jeu gars de l'autre pour moi tenez
pascal alors je vous écris c'est ma
fille qui les a prêtés elle les avait
dans sa classe l'année dernière
puisqu'il ya 22 ans susie morgenstern a
écrit un livre qui s'appelle joker dans
lequel un professeur hulbert inventer
des joker pour ses élèves alors un joker
pour arriver en retard à l'école un
autre pour ne pas faire ses devoirs et
ça a tellement marqué la littérature
jeunesse que des instituteurs et bien
s'en sont inspirés et aujourd'hui encore
et bien ça se poursuit j'imagine que
c'est la suite alors ces fameux petit
joker que j'ai là et oui ça c est bien
c'est publié ce mois-ci ccpl m joker et
c'est publié à l'édition l'école des
loisirs alors c'est pareil que le
premier tome ans est une ode à l'école
fantaisistes et humaniste on retrouve le
m un peu dépité en bus qu'il ne
travaille plus il est à la retraite
heureusement on l'appelle à la rescousse
comme directeur et ils recommencent à
distribuer des joker aux élèves mais
aussi aux professeurs il leur demande de
créer une chorale de devenir photographe
et ses tâches et bien qu'ils paraissent
un peu superflu deviennent essentiels
alors je vous conseille ce livre parce
que l'auteur s'est toujours amené
beaucoup de fantaisie et d'humour ainsi
que le dessinateur serge bloch est alors
vraiment mettre joker va vite devenir un
classique je pense et va vite rejoindre
les salles de classe des cours
élémentaires c'est super vous nous aviez
premier fantaisie pour cette rentrée
pour terminer votre sélection livre on
va parler alexandra une petite question
là pour nos amis qui chante avec nous
sur ce plateau combien de verres un
alexandrin félicien à votre avis 13-13
pour vous d'accord 12 12 soit la c12 je
procède d'une bêtise c'est pas grave
par exemple on a besoin souvent d'un
plus petit que soi voilà ça fait douze
parfait pour vous pour y aller tiphaine
en alexandrins s'il vous plaît attention
vallée compter les vérins alors par
exemple quelques alexandrins d'alexandre
jardin ça vous va oui par exemple parce
que là on était plutôt sur les verres à
boire de félicien qui lui en avait 13
dans le coeur continue à nous faire de
la poésie je pense que ça me ferait pas
mieux alors le roman s'appelle bande de
poète il est publié par casterman et il
est écrit intégralement en verre je vous
cache pas qu'au début c'est un petit peu
perturbant mais on s'y fait car
l'histoire de julien est vraiment très
intéressante et elle plaira aux
collégiens il entre en sixième dans un
collège qui lui fait un peu peur parce
que c'est le collège de la cité et lui
c'est le fils du maire qui habite au
centre ville vous voyez l'idée il a peur
de ne pas réussir à s'intégrer et au
début c'est assez difficile alors on
trouve dans ce roman tout ce qui fait un
bon roman adolescents une histoire
d'amour des rivalités entre garçons une
passion pour la musique bref vous allez
adorer si vous êtes au collège je vous
le conseille c'est une vraie réussite et
l'auteur alexandre jardin a réussi à
remettre au goût du jour les alexandrins
parce que figurez-vous que la poésie et
bien ce n'est pas démodé pascal d'or
merci tiphaine vous reviendrez avec de
nouveaux livres dans votre tout nouveau
cartable pour cette rentrée parce
qu'évidemment vous êtes formidables et
votre sélection est à retrouver sur les
réseaux sociaux et à bientôt pour
d'autres choix de lecture médine
bourgogne franche comté